you know in la
the the scene is this is probably the
best that it's been
in a very long time man as far as
camaraderie is concerned
um you know i was talking to like jason
cash and a few other guys just about
like
you know everybody in la it seems like
they [ __ ] with each other
you know and there's obviously politics
that come with a lot of [ __ ] you know
what i mean but for the most part
i feel like um you'll see ruchi getting
on songs with
kailyn and you'll see you guys doing a
project together and
you're talking about doing a whole joint
with draco like why do you think like
now the scene in la
seem so united as we're in the past it
felt very divided
i feel like we seen it work
you know other places you know what i'm
saying we kind of see how
they do things and we talk about you
know i'm saying states that haven't been
on top for years now
you know what i'm saying and we kind of
realizing that
we stronger together so
i feel like that's that's really the
spark of a lot of collaborations right
now in the west
like atlanta like atlanta's had it for
how long
they moved together so i'm crazy what do
you think blasto
yeah i mean i i just feel like it's it's
that young [ __ ] energy
like we we see what he said like
young doug like he moved like a boss
like we feel like bosses now so
we gonna run this [ __ ] how we want to
run it and shout out to the ogs that
paved the way but you know we got to
carry the torch
for the next generation so we've seen
what they did wrong and right
and now we can add our sauce to it